all right good afternoon everybody
everybody is here for biology either
three three one oh or four three one oh
not French literature or the modern
novel or any of that stuff right okay we
were in the wrong room before that's why
I asked okay so you should be registered
for one of these two courses let me tell
you a little bit about both of them
before we start talking about viruses so
I'm Vincent rock and yellow
I'm a professor up at the medical school
campus I've been up there for almost
thirty years working on viruses and
that's my email address if you have any
questions any time just email also and I
also am on Twitter Saul silverstein
sitting in the back in the corner
raising his hand say hi to Saul he is
that whore guy he's a professor also
slightly older than I am also up at the
Medical School has worked on viruses
also for longer than I and he will be
giving some lectures he'll be here
almost every lecture and so avail
yourself of his expertise as well and
his email is he rsjs six you can tell
how old we are because we have really
known low numbers
VRR one right and SJS six I don't know
how that work because you were
performing
okay and finally RTA for the courses
esta Francisco as there is my PhD
student working on viruses
okay so avail yourself of our expertise
we're here to help you learn about
biology and that's her email address so
a few mechanics about the course we are
on course works or I have a separate
website because some people don't go to
coursework so I have two different
places same material mostly duplicated
at both court places so course works as
one or this website which is very long
so I've made a I've done a URL
shortening bitly slash Cu virology bi te
ly / Cu virology but can you hear me in
the back with all the noise it's okay
yeah can you we have to close one of
these because it's too loud I'm sorry
yes thank you
so go to those websites to find out I
post all the slides ahead of time as a
PDF so you can take them with you print
them out do whatever you want take notes
on them and then I'm recording this I'm
recording the slides I will put it up as
a videocast for every lecture and you'll
find them there so within a day or two
after a lecture so last year about half
the class showed up for every lecture
because if you if you can just hear me
on a podcast you don't have to come and
I think they did just as well as
everyone else so it's your option I
would love to see your smiling faces and
have you ask great questions but if you
can't make it that's fine so on the
websites you'll have the schedule for
all the lectures there are readings for
each lecture there are textbook readings
the textbook has been ordered it should
be in the bookstore in a couple of days
there are assigned readings and I will
also post there the screencasts and the
PDFs before the lecture okay and there's
a separate course works page for
graduate students and undergrads any
grad students here taking the course one
okay so the grad students also have a
Friday session right and so the
undergrads don't have to go to that but
for the grad students they have to do
more to get extra credit and if there's
only one student going I'm not sure
we'll do it so we'll have to talk about
that okay maybe they just didn't come
today all right so all that is on the
website as well as the grading we have
three exams we have a weekly online quiz
to make sure you're keeping up very
short and for graduate students
something more no she doesn't want to
learn about viruses today
the textbook is principles of our ology
third edition I strongly recommend it
you may be able to get along without it
you could try it initially but it will
fill in all the gaps that I miss it will
have more than you need to know but if I
if you don't understand something and I
can't explain it and neither can soul or
Esther perhaps the textbook will but
it's a great book and it will keep you
in biology for the rest of your lives
one of the goals of this course is to
have you take viral adji with you
through whatever you do in life because
it's important I want you to understand
all aspects of our ology and not be
confused as most people are in this
textbook we'll help you do that I also
want you to take a look periodically at
my blog I do a blog I really believe in
using social media to teach social media
meaning interactive where people can
post on their own and they can comment
so I do a blog where I write
periodically various things and I also
do a podcast called this week in biology
where me and a couple of my viral adji
colleagues sit down and we talk about
the important of ayala G stories of the
week you don't have to do you don't have
to do every podcast you don't have to
read every blog post but what I want you
to do is to get inside of viral adji if
you listen to podcasts and read the post
you will see and think about what
biologists are thinking about and it
will help you immerse you in the course
and make it much more easier for you if
you just hear things about virology over
and over that will really enforce the
learning okay so those are all the
materials we use for the course once
again the textbooks try and read the
chapter ahead of time I have a specific
one associated with each lecture the
blog in the podcast okay so this is an
example of a blog post I write about
something that's interesting to me it
just pops into my head I read a paper
and I try and explain it and this is
written for the lay public and you will
find if you go here I allow comments by
anyone it's a very interesting
interaction with the public because
there are lots of very interesting
diseases
yeah caused by viruses these days the
public is very engaged about it
vaccination for example is a big issue
with the public and so a lot of people
comment here and you will see very
interesting comments this is the website
for the podcast every week we have an
episode with particular topics and this
one we covered three different stories
and again I have a couple of my Rowlett
my virology colleagues joining me you
can play it right here on the webpage or
you can download it so take advantage of
those again try and see how we are
thinking about viruses not just a
lecture here where I I'm talking at you
but casual conversations and you can
learn I think a lot more by listening in
that way okay that's the mechanics of
the course if you have any questions
come up afterwards
office hours by the way will be on
Wednesdays which is today right after
this lecture in this room okay we have
viruses everywhere we survive in a sea
of viruses we eat and breathe billions
of them on a regular basis for example
when you breathe your breathing about
eight six liters of air a minute it's a
huge amount of air you're sampling the
air which is full of viruses we eat all
kinds of food of course which is also
contaminated we touch all kinds of
things this doorknob which may have been
touched by thousands of people in the
course of the week is probably covered
with viruses and then we take our
fingers we put them in their eyes and
our mouths and we introduce viruses to
us every milliliter of seawater has more
than a million virus particles next time
you go swimming you take a mouthful of
water just think of all the viruses that
you're putting in your mouth even if you
don't swallow that salty water you're
putting viruses in there
we carry viral genomes as part of our
genetic material each and every one of
you has in your genome the information
to produce one or more viruses viruses
also infect other things besides humans
of course they infect our pets the
animals that we grow for food pigs cows
sheep and goats wildlife plane
insects anything living has a virus that
infects it so they're everywhere and
viral infection can cross from one
animal to another there may be a virus
of wild chimpanzees and they can cross
into humans and that happens all the
time and these are called a zoonotic
infections and we'll devote an entire
lecture just to talking about those
let's focus in on one type of virus and
I'll give you some numbers to emphasize
just how staggering the numbers are so
this is a bacteriophage and the cover of
the journal Cell there are more than 10
to the 30th bacteria phage particles in
all the waters of the world this is an
estimate made by sampling phages in
different parts of the world and to the
30th this is a huge number this is
inconceivable really biology
to Betty the hits his loss so
bacteriophage weighs about a femto gram
10 to the minus 15 grams so if you
multiply that by 10 to the 30th it turns
out that the biomass on earth of
bacterial viruses alone so these are
just viruses that infect bacteria not us
exceeds the biomass of elephants by more
than a thousandfold so that gives you an
idea your elephant is a big thing right
by more than the thousand fold now I
know they're not a lot of elephants left
but still that's a lot and these are
microscope sub microscopic entities so
10 to the 30th is huge here's another
way to look at it so the length of a
head-to-tail line of 10 to the 30th
phages is more than 200 million light
years and if you want you can go to the
website where this fellow made this
calculation that's the link to it there
how much is 200 million light years
that's another inconceivable number well
the closest galaxy to us the Milky Way
is the Andromeda galaxy which is two and
a half million light years away so
that's a hundred times more the phages
would stretch into space a hundred times
further than the nearest galaxy you
can't even see this with the naked eye
at night so this is incredible it's a
lot of particles whales that's a whale
they're whales are commonly infected by
these tiny DNA RNA viruses called
calluses and whales these viruses in in
people can end in marine mammals can
cause a variety of infections in marine
animals like whales and seals dolphins
they can cause rashes and blisters and
gastroenteritis and they can infect
humans in fact a very common way of them
being transmitted is in these theme
parks where they have the whales jumping
out of the water and the people are
sitting next to them and the whales are
splashing them and often the virus
crosses over into people in those
situations so these viruses can infect
humans infected whales secrete more than
10 to the 13th Calissa viruses a day
okay each whale every day is secreting
this into the ocean so this is adding to
the biomass of viruses in the ocean it's
a huge number so one of the things I
want you to get from all
this is that when we talk about viruses
the numbers are astronomical they're
bigger than anything else that we know
about on earth and in the course of this
course we will try and understand why
viruses produce such large numbers of
progeny there are 10 to the 16th HIV
genomes on the planet right now it's
another big number and this is of course
because millions and millions of people
are infected and each infected person
makes a huge number of particles every
day with this number of genomes it's
possible that there are already genomes
that exist that are resistant to all the
drugs we have we have over 20 of them or
that we'll ever discover if we keep
making drugs for years and years and
years somewhere out there there's
already a resistant virus and this is
one of the reasons why we have to use
combination drug therapy to treat a
virus like HIV and we'll talk about this
in some detail despite all of this
despite the viruses on the doorknob and
floating around in this room we're
pretty healthy most of the time and
that's because we have a great defense
system that has evolved along with
viruses to fight infections viruses has
have been with us since the beginning of
life maybe even before some people
believe and so life has evolved along
with viruses infecting them so they have
in order to survive they have to evolve
defense mechanisms so we have great
immune systems that keep us healthy most
of the time but if our immune system is
down if it's defective or suppressed so
if you get an organ transplant and you
receive drugs to immunosuppressed you so
you won't reject the transplant your
immune system is dampened or if you have
AIDS in which case you're also
immunosuppressed because the virus is
killing the cells of your immune system
then you have problems with common virus
infections that in bacterial and fungal
as well that would normally be nothing
or benign to us but is lethal and
immunosuppressed person so how infected
are we exactly a couple of slides to
emphasize this every one of you is
probably infected with at least two of
the nine three of the nine I think you
said that last year right and let's see
which three we have these are the nine
known herpes viruses simplex one and two
vzv cytomegalovirus epstein-barr hhv-6
seven and eight and B so which three
would everyone have soul
okay HSV one vzv and EBV three of the
nine known herpes viruses the B virus is
100% lethal so none of you are infected
with that and once infected with any of
these you are infected for life and
every one of your cells is infected with
viruses you have thousands of copies of
retrovirus genomes integrated into your
DNA about 8% of your DNA your genomic
DNA is made up of these retrovirus
sequences now in us they happen to be
defective they have mutations in them so
they don't produce virus particles but
in other animals these endogenous
retroviruses as we call them do produce
infected virya infectious of Erie ons
you will pass these retrovirus sequences
on to your children and they will do the
same on and on and on and this has
probably been going on as long as there
have been Homo sapiens and probably the
hominids before that and it's an
interesting question why do we have
eight percent of our genome as
retroviral sequences maybe they are
doing something for us that we don't
know about so we'll talk about that as
well in another lecture what are the
genomes doing there do they help us at
all
you're also a reservoir for viruses that
have set up residents and your longings
in your GI tract your lungs and GI tract
are constantly sampling the environment
so you have lots of viruses in them a
few other places as well we're all
colonized by adenoviruses coronaviruses
rhinoviruses these are common viruses
that cause respiratory infections as you
know we actually have more bacteria in
us than human cells and a main place
where that is
then cut and these are good for us the
particular blend of bacteria that we
each have in our guts is important for
our well-being and they have their own
viruses as well and we're just beginning
to study those and understand the
beneficial role of these viruses for
those bacteria they've been with us as I
said since we've evolved and probably
before that as well now this is a slide
I just stuck in this morning because we
heard a lecture from a virologist today
by the name of Herbert virgin and he
showed this slide which is the estimated
burden of chronic viral infections in
humans now chronic viral infection is
one that goes on for years and years
we'll talk about the different kinds of
infections later on but these viral
infections go on for years and years and
this is a graph showing on the y-axis
the estimated number of infected
individuals in the millions so we have
10 to the 0 up to 10 to the 4th million
so population of the world is almost 7
billion people or so which would be
somewhere in here so you can see some of
these viruses infect everyone the
endogenous retroviruses are in every one
so that's the world's population there
and then we have an L ov Iris's which
are curious DNA viruses no one has any
clue what they are doing if they cause
any disease but most people seem to be
infected with them and here here are our
herpes viruses look HHV 7 & 8 v zv e bv
c and v all infecting large proportions
of the population other herpes viruses
as well then we go down in prevalence as
we reach htlv-1 human t-cell leukemia
virus one hepatitis delta virus HIV and
some in between so the burden of chronic
viral infections upon their own is huge
and we think not all of these are bad I
don't want you to end up at the end of
this course thinking that all viruses
are bad some of them are probably good
in fact many of them are probably good
for us in a variety of ways and
hopefully we get to talk about that as
well so I think viruses are amazing you
probably have some fascination with them
or else you wouldn't be here and this
course is going to tell you why I think
they're amazing and why they're amazing
how do they get to be amazing
how do they work so I want you to see
the big picture in this course I don't
want to teach you 50 different viruses
and how they replicate and how they
cause disease that's not what this
course is about that would be a survey
course and I don't believe in that kind
of teaching not at this level I want you
to see the big picture the overview so
you can look at every Veni given virus
and figure out how it replicates and how
it causes disease so I want you to learn
general things about replication spread
and disease-causing I want you to think
about I'll show you how to think about
virology as an integrated discipline and
again not a collection of viruses
diseases genes but the whole picture and
this will be clear to you by the end I
think if it is not now I also want you
to appreciate what viruses do to pervert
pervade the ecosystem to the extent that
we have just talked about today the
numbers that you see and then you'll
also learn the fundamentals about
viruses and these are things that most
people don't understand and that is why
they are frightened of viruses the
unknown is the most frightening thing
and I'm going to help you understand
viruses so you'll be less frightened
about them now virology requires that
you know a little bit about a lot of
subjects in biology viruses use cells in
order to replicate so you have to know
how cells work for example does everyone
know the difference between translation
and transcription
everyone knows because last year no not
everyone knew so I'm glad that you guys
do maybe you got a better background so
I'm gonna be saying translation
transcription nuclear import and if you
don't know what it means you better
either find out or ask me because you're
gonna get lost because if you think when
I say translation that I mean RNA
synthesis that'll be a problem it's
going to be confusing and virology will
always test your ability to put things
together you're going to have to do that
you're going to have to integrate your
knowledge about how a cell works in
order to figure out how a virus genome
replicates for example now you have to
know certain facts and at different
points in this course I'll tell you that
the things you must memorize
not everything you're gonna have to
memorize certain things but you're never
going to be able to memorize all the
combinations of facts that tell you how
viruses work you're gonna have to think
okay so memorization is not enough I
want you to actively think and say does
this make sense
from what I know and of course there are
details to learn about different viruses
we will point those out and that is some
of the fun part about learning about how
viruses work now here's a very nice
quote from a writer that I happen to
like from Wired magazine in 2008 and I
think this may summarize the philosophy
in us teaching this course one of the
reasons kids get bored by science is
that too many teachers presented as a
fuss fusty collection of facts for
memorization this is precisely wrong
science isn't about facts it's about the
quest for facts the scientific method
the process by which we hash through
confusing thickets of ignorance it's
dynamic argumentative collaborative
competitive filled with flashes of crazy
excitement and hours of drudge work and
driven by ego our desire to be the one
who figures it out at least for now so
as we go along we will try and tell you
how we found these things these facts
that we are telling you about viruses
because I think that is really the basis
for science not the fact itself but how
we got to that point and this is a very
important point here which I can't
overemphasize we all like to think that
we do science to figure out things to
make life better for people it certainly
is a component but ego plays a huge role
ego being meaning I want to be the first
to figure this out and if that drives
science that's fine there happens to be
some untidy side effects of having big
egos in science but it does drive
science the desire to be the best and to
be the first is the main driver of
progress in science viruses infect every
living thing as I have said but
most people think that viruses are bad
news wrapped in a bit of protein I
forgot who said this scientists said
this not too long ago many maybe many
years ago they're not all bad news
many of them are and in fact we are
biased because scientists virologist
study the viruses that make you sick
because you want to figure out how to
prevent you from getting sick but there
are many viruses out there that don't
make you sick and that are not bad news
at all we'll try and emphasize those in
this course as well viruses do much more
than cause disease so the big picture I
want you to take away from this course
is that all viruses follow a simple
three-part savate strategy to survive
they all package their genomes inside a
particle used for transmission from host
to host so there's a genome and a
particle and the particle protects the
genome as it goes from one host to
another the genome has all the
information you need to make new viruses
we'll go through this infectious cycle
in this course and explain how it works
for different genome types and then
finally all the genomes can establish
themselves in a host population so that
they persist influenza viruses have been
with us for hundreds and hundreds
perhaps thousands of years that's
because the virus has evolved the
strategy to do that if it didn't it
would be gone so the genome encodes all
that information the ability to stay
within a population and when the virus
encounters a new host goes from a human
to an animal or vice versa the genome
can be plastic it can change to adapt to
the new host so if that's it then
why study virology why take this course
well the tactics to achieve that
three-part strategy are very diverse and
I want to tell you about them in this
course there are many different
particles out there with it with
countless diversity they're the size and
the nature of genomes are different
there are odd particles and they're very
interesting coding strategies so the
three-part strategy holds but the way
that viruses do it are very diverse and
I want you to learn about that and we'll
try and make sense
to unify it in a way that you can
understand it there are two simple facts
though that we can use to simplify this
enormous diversity and the first is that
all viral genomes are molecular
parasites that is they can only function
after they get into a cell a virus
cannot do anything on its own
the virus is sitting on these chairs or
floating in the air will do so forever
until they degrade and break apart
unless they encounter a host and cells
within that host in which they can
multiply so they are parasites they are
molecular parasites and we'll see in
this course the extent to which viruses
are parasitic in different kinds of
viruses have different levels of
parasitism some completely depend on the
host for everything some viruses have
only one or two genes whereas many
viruses are huge and can code hundreds
of genes and are much less dependent on
the host but all of them are parasites
at least the ones that we know now are
parasites and the second very important
unifying principle is that all viruses
have to make messenger RNA and that
messenger RNA has to be able to be
translated by host ribosomes so no
matter what the virus if you just think
of this one fact throughout this course
it will help you enormous Lee every
virus has to make mRNA at some point no
matter what else goes on it has to make
mRNA and it has to be translated from by
the host so they are also parasites of
the host protein synthesis machinery the
we don't know of any virus that encodes
its own translation complete translation
machinery and that of course includes
ribosomes tRNAs all the amino acids the
synthetases and so forth that you need
to make proteins from an RNA template no
virus can do that on its own so they're
obligate ly devoted to using the host
translation system now because of this
because of the parasitic nature of
viruses when you study them you by
definition learn about the hostess
well so if you understand how a virus
parasitizes the host translation system
how it utilizes it you will learn about
the hosts and viruses in fact they've
turned out to be wonderful probes for
understanding host functions now a word
of warning be careful about
anthropomorphic characterizations of
viruses what do I mean by that viruses
don't think what you say obviously they
don't have brains but people often say a
virus will employ this strategy or
ensure its survival exhibit display it's
there many many words in fact there's a
little bit of text in Chapter one that
deals with all the words that we don't
like to use because the point is it's
not just an exercise it gets you to
thinking about viruses as passive
vehicles viruses have evolved to undergo
chemical reactions which propagate them
they don't want to do something they
don't want to kill a host they don't
want to make a lot of particles it's
just a chemical reaction and I think if
you avoid using human-like words to
characterize what viruses do you set
yourself in a better frame of mind for
understanding how viral replication
cycles a cart it's very hard to do
I'll slip all the time in in talking to
you and in fact you can probably find in
our textbook all the mistakes we made
where we left the irises doing something
in but I really think it's a good
exercise to undertake to get you
thinking about how viruses work in a
correct way so they don't achieve their
goals in a human centered manner and
here's the key they survive because they
make huge numbers of mutants at every
replication cycle those big numbers that
I showed you earlier they're all
consequence of making a lot of particles
every replication cycle more than any
other form of existence on earth they
make more of themselves more progeny in
a given time than anything else and
that's why they're successful because a
lot of those particles are no good they
don't work under certain conditions the
ill adapted are gone they never
replicate and if condition changes in an
animal or a host species there are
viruses there that can take advantage of
that because there's so many of them
because there are millions and millions
of particles produced in every cycle
there's always one that can take
advantage of a different condition a
different animal walking by a different
weather ultraviolet rays new name it
it's really a beautiful example of
selection of the fittest and they're
great
Darwinian machines I think they're that
there's no better model for the concept
of survival of the fittest so Darwin
knew about viruses that's what he would
have studied because it's a lot easier
than cataloguing Birds on a remote
island he can grow billions of viruses
in a day and watch evolution occur in
your cell cultures so think let's think
about this a little bit more viruses of
course depend on their hosts for
survival if it weren't any hosts on
earth or what there weren't life there
wouldn't be any viruses so what does
that mean if the virus is too successful
if it kills their hosts then it doesn't
have a host to grow in right on the
other hand if viruses are too passive
and the host defense has overcome an
infection for example the virus can be
eliminated as well so it's a little
paradoxical right you have to have a
balance between killing and existing
with the host and this has been debated
by many many people for years it's a
common misconception that viruses
evolved to get more virulent for humans
so I saw in the past year in almost
every newspaper the notion that this
influenza pandemic strain was going to
evolve to get more virulent in people
why would it do that it makes no sense
whatsoever why would it kill and
debilitate the host and affect its
spread now I'm giving a little
anthropomorphic characterization here I
don't mean to but in terms of selection
and propagation it makes more sense for
the virus to coexist peacefully with the
host there are examples of virus
infections that are terribly lethal but
they for the most part don't spread very
much yes
the Tappan Zee who you ask you'll get
both answers some people think well
first there was a soup of before any
life there was an organic soup from
which life evolved some people think
viruses could actually replicate in that
soup before there were cells so that's
one because theoretically it's possible
you could have just a simple nucleic
acid genome multiplying in an organic
soup others think that cells cellular
life came first it's a big debate
because we don't have fossils like we do
for a lot of other evolutionary
questions but it's a lot of fun to talk
about we're gonna talk about evolution
and we'll we'll do that so how do you
balance this survival of the host and
survival of the virus this is a really
important underlying question you'll
want to kill the hosts off because then
you have no host to multiply in but you
can't be wimpy otherwise you're not
gonna get anywhere as well so there's an
incredible balance and this is one of
the big questions that viola gist try
and understand it's very difficult to
study in people so we turn to other
models for doing that and all of the
twists and turns that allow viruses to
propagate and whether it be in a cell or
a tissue or an entire organism or in the
whole population this provides insight
into mechanisms that we couldn't study
any other way and that's another theme
in this course we can study aspects of
life that you can't do without virus
infections so when this course is over
and not only it's going to be spring
which is really nice you will have
significantly better insight into how
cells work and how they interact not
just viruses because viruses are wedges
or hooks they target processes to their
advantage so when I explained how a
virus replicates you're going to better
understand the cellular process you're
going to have an a better knowledge of
the way information is stored and
decoded in viral genomes and this is far
more diverse and complicated than occurs
in our cells for example many many
different stress
oh geez we have very tiny genomes how
can you pack so much information into a
tiny viral genome and have it work we
also will have a basic understanding of
viral pathogenesis which is the process
by which viruses cause disease and
infectious disease in general you'll be
able to better understand what's
happening to you when you get sick from
a viral infection and when your family
says to you should I be vaccinated
you'll be able to make a better decision
about that as well so why you get why do
you feel badly when you get a viral
infection the immunology will explain
that and that's one of the things you'll
be able to do when the course is over in
addition you'll be able to defend these
assertions but you may disagree with me
which is fine but I think you'll see by
the end of the course that viruses have
more biological diversity than than all
the rest of life
well not life because I don't think
they're living but let's just say the
bacterial plant and animal kingdoms put
together far greater biological
diversity we are actually not at the top
of the food chain
I think viruses are I think the tiny may
well inherit the earth although they
can't get rid of us otherwise they
wouldn't be able to propagate and
despite being very small most viruses it
turns out have less than 15 genes we
have tens of thousands of genes in us
some viruses only have one gene and
that's enough for them to propagate it
be very successful they excel at
survival in wood is a pretty harsh world
and the molecular biology is very
sophisticated and finally virus host
interactions define
interactions of fundamental and
practical significance that we really
need to understand if we want to protect
against serious virus infections we have
very very rudimentary knowledge of how
viruses and hosts interact but we're
getting better at it and I hope to tell
you some of the results that we've had
finally I want you to come out of this
course and be able to look at a news
report like this terrible one from CNN
which focuses on all the sensationalism
of swine flu you'll be able to read
newspaper articles online articles and
blogs and websites and you'll say this
is nonsense this can't be
it's just sensationalism and and
remember that newspapers and TV programs
have to be sensational to make money for
some reason that's what people respond
to so here we have a CNN headline from
actually one of my readers on the blog
sent this to me last year this this was
from last summer I believe a paper came
out in the New England Journal of
Medicine where they had infected ferrets
with the new pandemic influenza virus
and so they put this headline up without
telling the listeners that this referred
to experiments in a ferret and it can
ravage the lung spreads through
respiratory systems causes lesions
doesn't stay in the head like seasonal
flu I don't know what that means because
flu typically is a lower respiratory
tract infection the last point survivors
of 1918 flu are immune that's true
because the virus is quite related
antigenically to that and we'll talk
about that but an animal model is great
for understanding aspects of virology
but it turns out that the virus was
quite benign in people for the most part
and so the animal results did not
predict what was happening in people but
it was just a splashy sensationalist
headline and this is what we're trying
to combat so I want you to be able to
look beyond this look through this kind
of sensationalism so we're going to talk
mainly about animal viruses in this
course but we will talk about some
viruses that infect bacteria because
they are great model systems not not a
lot but enough to explain certain
principles and many viruses will not pay
any attention to sadly because of time
constraints but once you take this
course you'll be in love with viral adji
and you'll be following viruses for the
rest of your lives so I'm not worried
about that so let's talk a little bit
about viral origins and history how old
are viruses well without with a few
exceptions and we'll talk about the
exceptions there's no fossil record so
it's very difficult to know how old they
are you can get estimates for how old
they are by looking at the sequence
change so viruses change in their
sequence a certain amount each year it's
called a molecular clock and you can
back calculate using a molecular clock
cat
halation and for some viruses it places
them among the dinosaurs in 150 million
years ago and this is all all possible
now because we can sequence viral
genomes and there's a whole new area of
bioinformatics that uses mathematical
algorithms to do these calculations in
theory as I mentioned earlier viruses
could predate cellular life they could
have existed in a soup we'll talk a
little bit about those early origins but
where my feeling is that probably
viruses were around even before cellular
life evolved but I think it will be hard
to prove we do have lots of early
records of virus infections in
prehistory alright so let me tell you a
few of those so there are ancient
references to viral diseases so here we
have from 700 BC from the Iliad and it
says here this firebrand rabid Hector
leads the charge so rabid referring to
this virus disease passed on to humans
by rabid animals and they didn't know it
was a virus at the time but it meant
that viruses were around and here's
another one from about 1500 to 1300 BC
it's an Egyptian carving which shows
this young priest with this leg it's
called drop foot and a withered calf
which is very typical of polio so we
think this is the first recorded
characterization of polio myelitis which
is also caused by a virus so the
historical records are full of
references to diseases which when we
look at them now look very much like
either viral or bacterial diseases and
there are entire books written on this
subject which discussed for example how
battles were lost due to infectious
diseases and of course not no one knew
what these were but clearly the virus
infections were around as long as as
people were around you can also
understand from looking at the way
people prevented virus infections so as
long ago as the 11th century there were
practices in place to prevent virus
infections again that wasn't known that
they were virus infections without
knowledge of the
agent and a very famous practice was
called variolation
and smallpox is a disease that we can
very clearly see in historical records
because it has very prominent symptoms
it has a very prominent rash it's fatal
and so we can track it historically now
what was noticed very early on was that
once you got smallpox if you weren't
killed by the disease you survived then
you never got it again
so people were smart they said hmm I
wonder if I naturally infect myself or
give myself this disease can I protect
myself so the practice of very very
elation arose where they would take the
pustules from a smallpox victim and
these are full of virus they would grind
them up and inject them into someone
else and if you didn't die from that
because you did often you were protected
against the disease and this is actually
something brought to the UK England in
the 1700s by lady Montague who was the
wife of the Turkish ambassador and she
went to Turkey and found this practice
being done where you would go to a woman
who had a little room and she would have
a vial full of ground-up crusts from
smallpox victims and you would give her
a vein and she would shove some into it
and as I said that has a lot of virus in
it and if you didn't die you would be
protected so these are the first
examples of immunization but it wasn't
until the later 1700s that Edward Jenner
established true vaccination Jenner
realized you can't infect people with
the agent that causes the disease he
didn't know what the agent was but he
knew there were forms of the disease
that were milder so his idea was to use
that and when we talk about vaccines
we'll go through that now the concept of
microorganisms has not developed yet at
this point in history and really the
first beginnings were from the Dutch
lens maker
li-huei Nowak he made lenses for glasses
and all sorts of telescopes
and he made a microscope one day you've
probably seen images of this very crude
microscope but he started looking at
things under it and he found these wee
animals things moving around microbes
bacteria yeasts fungi
and from that work initially became the
acceptance of the idea that there are
things smaller than us microorganisms
and past it took pasture to show in the
1800's that these are generated by
reproduction they don't spontaneously
reproduce it was a whole train of
non-scientific thought the where people
thought that these we animal culs these
microbes arose by spontaneous generation
huge debates between pastor and his
opponents but he finally prevailed and
showed that these reproduced not by
spontaneous generation but the germ
theory of disease which links a microbe
to disease and humans wasn't formally
established until robert korkin did so
in Germany in 1879 he said we have
microorganisms and some of them can
cause disease and he proved it but he
didn't know anything about viruses yet
these are all bacteria that we know now
now this is how Pasteur got around the
problem of spontaneous generation so he
took a flask with broth in it in which
microorganisms could grow and he boiled
it to sterilize it and nothing would
grow in it unless he put air into the
neck so any contaminating microorganisms
from the environment would get in here
they would be stuck down here they would
never make it up here and these flasks
actually still existed the Pasteur
museum in Paris they're still not
contaminated so we did a podcast about
this there's a professor at Columbia
who's a historian of science and he
talked about this in our podcast number
35 so that was the proof that
microorganisms reproduced viruses came
around about the end of the 1800s the
first virus to be discovered was one
that infects plants and this will be a
theme recurring you'll see many
discoveries in biology occurred using
plant viruses this is a tobacco leaf and
it's infected with a virus that causes
these models spots on it eventually this
leaf will wither up and die and if you
want to grow tobacco this is very bad
for cigars and cigarettes and so forth
so the scientists at the end of the 18
others was trying to figure out what
caused this and back in those days the
standard method which Pasteur had
developed would be to take what you
suspect to be a microorganism and filter
out the liquid take the concentrated
microorganism and in this case rub it on
the leaf well this fellow did this over
and over and what he found was that what
caused the infection of the leaf was
actually going through the filter so
this is what these filters look like
these are called porcelain filters you
basically had a vacuum flask and then
you have this inverted this chamber up
here you could pour in liquid up here
that's what the yellow material is and
this is the porcelain filter and have
very fine holes in it which would stop
bacteria from going through so they
learned this empirically by making
porcelain with different sized pores and
so the bacteria would remain here and
what went through was sterile and what
was found with tobacco mosaic disease
was that the agent of the disease was
down here
it wasn't hung up by the filter and this
was a fellow named Ivanov skee who did
this in 1892 he found that the agent of
the disease tobacco mosaic disease
passes through the filter okay so you
filter it you take this liquid you put
it on a leaf the leaf gets infected and
that didn't make sense to anyone because
up to that point they everyone
understood that microorganisms were
retained by these filters so Beit Ivanov
skee said well it's a really small
microbe and he glad to let it go
we we cite that as the beginning of
Virology but he really didn't understand
that he was working with viruses it was
about six years later Bayer Inc made the
same finding the filtrate is what causes
infection of the leaves but he said ah
this is a distinct pathogen this is just
not not just the microbe that we've been
studying so far this is something new he
didn't know what it was but he made the
conceptual leap that this is a new kind
of agent and that's really the beginning
of virology in 1898 the first animal
virus was discovered the agent of
foot-and-mouth disease which is a
disease
of cattle and the key concept here is
not only that these agents are small but
they need a host to replicate they don't
grow in broth so pastures microorganisms
would grow in broth but if he took these
filtrates of tobacco leaves they
wouldn't grow in any kind of broth you
had to put them on our cell in the same
with the foot and mouth disease agent
you could only you had to put it in an
animal there were no cell cultures back
then and it would only grow in the
animal so very small and Rep needs a
host to replicate and from that arose
the concept of virus and back then they
used these porcelain filters which had a
pore size of about 0.2 microns all right
a micrometer is one millionth of a meter
this is really small and this this held
as a definition of a virus until maybe
five years ago as we'll see now there
are some viruses that are bigger so
we're not quite sure where to put them
anymore but point to micron filters were
the defining agent for the size of
viruses for many years so here are some
of the years of virus discovery 1901 the
first human virus yellow fever 1903
rabies variola smallpox 1906 leukemia
virus and polio in 1908 and a sarcoma
virus in 1911 bacteria phages were
discovered in 1915 and then flew not
till 1933 and then shortly after the
isolation of influenza virus in the
1940s the first vaccines against those
viruses were made so virus means toxin
or poison in Latin that's where the name
comes from and I will use a term many
times in this course probably every
lecture virion so we'll say virus is a
generic term when we furtive viruses
we're just talking about the general
concept of a virus but a virion is
actually the infectious particle okay so
remember that virion whenever I say
virion it means a specific thing and the
particle has to be infectious it's not
an on infectious particle that's an on
infectious particle virion is the
infectious particle so here are some
examples these are electron micrographs
in 1940s the electron micrograph was
developed microscope was developed we
got the ability
to see what these things were that we're
passing through 0.2 micron filters and
up on the upper left is a bacteriophage
this is one of the funkier looking ones
it has tails you've seen these pictures
before a neck and a head where the
nucleic acid is here is tobacco mosaic
virus it is a long rod and the nucleic
acid is wrapped up in it this is a
rhabdo virus like rabies there
bullet-shaped virions and a gee i don't
know what this virus is i forgot a
rotavirus for example a non envelope
virus so when people began to look under
the microscope that oh wow these are
discrete particles associated with this
infectivity we know many details about
viruses let me shut the light off for
this one
this is poliovirus and since the 1980s
late 1970s actually we can figure out
the three-dimensional structure of
viruses I'm sorry this should be in
white because it tells you the chemical
formula for this virus which is
poliovirus
you can see it has three hundred and
thirty-two thousand six hundred and
fifty-two carbon atoms and hydrogen
nitrogen oxygen phosphorus and sulfur so
we know the exact chemical composition
because we know the sequence of all of
the proteins of this virus but actually
that chemical formula isn't correct it's
just an average because as you'll see
every virus in a solution is different
it has a different genome sequence so
the precise composition of phosphorus
and carbon and so forth is different
from each virus one to another so this
brings us to the question what is a
virus I've been telling you that some
history and what we're going to learn
but what is it what's the definition
well it's a very small infectious
obligate intracellular parasite and this
definition has held for years the very
small is kind of problematic now because
there are some pretty big viruses as you
will see that you can actually see in a
light microscope but anyway we'll use
this as a working death
a parasite of course is an organism that
benefits at the expense of a host
usually a different organism so viruses
are parasites and they're obligate
intracellular parasites they have to go
inside a cell you know there many kinds
of parasites that live in your
intestines worms of various sorts for
intestines they are not within your
cells viruses have to reproduce within
your cells intracellular parasites now I
do not think that virus particles are
living I think I shut it off okay I do
not think that virus particles are
living its objecting to my saying that
to you many people debate this but the
particle not virus the particle the
virion I should actually have virions
are not living a virion is just a
chemical it's not living and has a
potential to live when it goes into a
cell so maybe you could view the
infected cell is living but the particle
itself is not living but this is debated
and that's just my view and you can have
your own as well I think there are
chemicals and cannot reproduce on their
own you need a cellular host in order to
reproduce so on my blog I put a poll
about a year ago our virus is alive you
should go take this poll at some point
when you feel confident in your answer
here's the link
I had the options where yes no or they
are something in between or I don't know
now I shouldn't have put this something
in between because too many people
picked it but we have 1,500 responses
29% 32 33 so it's pretty evenly divided
among the three so I don't know who's
answering this I think it's all kinds of
people I think there's some biologists
here as well as non scientists as well
but when you feel you can answer this
question or maybe you already have an
opinion go there and take the survey
now viruses are very small as I said
here's a picture that gives you some
idea of that so here's a carbon atom up
here so I'll be obviously magnified a
lot and these are all various structures
in at the right scale for carbon so
here's a tRNA an antibody myosin actin
and here's a ribosome and poliovirus so
you can see polio is about the
of a ribosome considerably bigger than
carbon now we take this whole panel and
we we shrink it so it's this size and
now we have some other viruses that are
really big and so that's why we have to
shrink these to go down we have HIV one
up here which is quite large tobacco
mosaic virus and then a bacteriophage
and here's e-coli so e-coli is huge and
these viruses are quite big but we have
another virus which I'll talk about in a
moment which is slightly bigger than you
coli at least in diameter so this gives
you some relative ideas about the size
of viruses now here is a cell with some
viruses near it to give you more of an
idea so here's a eukaryotic cell right
you got your nucleus here endoplasmic
reticulum Golgi mitochondria I'm helping
my kids study biology so I know all this
stuff and we have some virus particles
here at the surface and here's a
magnification the big guy is herpes
virus and this is polio virus so herpes
is quite large compared to the cell of
course this is a just a two-dimensional
slice the cell is actually has volume of
course it's going to be much bigger than
the virus but it gives you some kind of
idea of the size of viruses compared to
cells how many viruses can fit on the
head of a pin well it depends on the
virus of course but if it's a rhinovirus
one of the causes of the common cold you
could put 500 million on the head of a
pin but the bigger virus has many fewer
when you sneeze you fire an aerosol that
contains enough viruses to infect
thousands and we'll talk about that as
well very small what does that mean well
Mimi virus was discovered I don't know
about five years ago
the name means microbial mimic Mimi
virus was isolated from a water tower in
France and the the individuals who
isolated they thought it was they looked
at it under the microscope they thought
was a bacterium so they put it in the
freezer and it sat there for a couple of
years till they went back to it they
realized it was a virus it was just
really big it grows in a me bait in the
wild
and it's about 750 nanometers or 0.75
microns in diameter so remember the
filter we use to filter out the viruses
is 0.2 microns so this will not go
through the filter so if you use that
kind of filter to look for viruses you
will miss the me me viruses so you can't
use really point 2 micron as a
definition for viruses anymore because
we have these big ones the DNA this is a
double-stranded DNA virus it's huge 1.1
million base pairs with 1262 open
reading frames or potential proteins
this is huge
but some viruses only encode one protein
and it encodes many components of the
translation system trna synthetases
translation proteins T RNAs they even
come has components of DNA repair pak
pathways it's got a lot of genes so this
is getting to be a blurring virus
between real viruses and host cells and
what the interesting question is now are
we gonna find even bigger viruses that
run the continuum from the smallest
virus all the way up to the host cell
will we find a virus that has almost
everything it needs to replicate we'll
see
challenge is the frontier between
viruses and cells so these this is a
cell infected with me me viruses so this
is similar to the cell I showed you
before it's a nucleus actually that's
not the nucleus right here is the
nucleus and these are Mimi virus
particles mV you can see them this is
actually an electron micrograph but you
could see these in a infected cell in a
light microscope if you want to learn
more about these Mimi viruses there's a
website called giant virus dot org so
viral attributes what is a virus
continuing this discussion the genome is
either DNA or RNA so our genomes are DNA
but viruses can be either one in the
host cell the viral genome directs the
synthesis of new particles by cellular
systems new particles are made by
assembly from parts the viruses make the
parts and they're put together and the
progeny particles transmit the infection
to the next host or organism and then
the infectious cycle begins again so
these are again properties
a virus small obligate intracellular
pathogen para sites that have to go
through these steps to replicate when a
virus infects a cell it needs the cell
of course so a viral infection is an
exercise in cell biology these are some
of the functions of the cell that are
needed for viral propagation you need
translation of course you need energy
viruses can't make energy can't make ATP
they don't do respiration or what's the
other one fermentation nope can't do
that they need enzymes for replication
and assembly and transport pathways they
have to move stuff around the cell they
can't do it so they use cellular
transport pathway so when you study
virus replication you're going to study
all of these things that go on in cells
and this is a really important concept
that we'll come back to later viruses
replicate by assembling components it's
like an assembly line you make the parts
you put them together you get a virus
it's not binary fission like bacteria or
other cells and that you know take one
and break it in two and then two to four
and so forth it doesn't happen with
viruses you make the particles from
parts and that's reflected in these
growth curves which we will look at in
more detail later on we classify them by
the Linnaean system the binomial system
genus species here's the typical
hierarchical system and we typically use
genus and species for viruses there are
some families and some orders as well
and we don't usually go above the order
in classifying viruses do we classify
them by a variety of physical
characteristics the nature of the
nucleic acid the protein shell whether
there's an envelope or not and how big
the viruses these all go into
classifying the virus but now in the
most recent five years genomics is
really taken over in virus
classification so you can isolate the
new virus you don't even have to isolate
a virus you can get a sequence of a
virus and look at it have your
bioinformatics people look at the
sequence and they'll tell you where to
classify it you don't have to think
about any of this other stuff there's
actually some controversy about this in
the field but genomics has become very
important at classification so here's an
example
research crew went up went to Antarctica
went down I guess to Antarctica they
drilled holes in the ice there
apparently freshwater lakes down there
and they drilled holes in them and they
sampled the water and they just
sequenced the water they extracted
nucleic acids from the water and they
sequenced it's called deep sequencing
and they found 10,000 new virus species
just by sequencing it your sequence wit
and you you search the database and you
say there are 10,000 sequences here that
are all different I don't see any of
them in the database so you have new
virus sequences and it says here in
total the viruses were from 12 different
families some of which may be completely
new to science so you can put a virus in
a family just by looking at the sequence
nowadays so that's an example of what I
was telling you here's an example of how
you would classify a virus it's a very
nice site over in Switzerland called
viral zone that has all of this listed
out typical taxonomy we'll talk about
classifying the viruses according to
genome here's the family the genus and
examples of different species so family
genus and species for classification
there is a committee that deals with the
classification of viruses it's called
the ICT ICTV and they have a database
which is hosted at Columbia you can find
every virus at this database
so far there are about 40,000 virus
isolates from bacteria plants and
animals placed in three orders 73
families 287 Jenner and 1950 species but
these are the ones that have been
characterized there are a million
variants per milliliter of seawater and
we don't know what most of them are so
there's a lot more out there that we
have to learn about now we're going to
now move on for the rest of today and
then next time to talk about viral
genomes and the important breakthrough
here occurred in the 1950s when it was
shown that the viral nucleic acid genome
carried the information needed to build
viruses before that we didn't know how
new new viruses or organisms were even
built now now this seems very obvious
but that was one of the building blocks
of this field called molecular biology
you may remember the
in 1944 a couple of investigators at the
Rockefeller showed that the DNA of a
bacterium was the genetic information
but for viruses that wasn't known until
the 1950s and that was done by these two
investigators alfred hershey and
Margaret chase in 1952 they took a
bacteriophage and they labeled it with
two different kinds of radioactive
isotopes one to label the protein shell
or one to label the DNA and then they
took these radioactively tags bacteria
phages they infected bacteria and they
asked where does the label go so when
they labeled the protein they found that
there was nothing left in the cell after
the virus infected that so there was no
radioactive protein but if they labeled
the DNA you can do that with with
phosphorous p32 they found that the
label went inside the bacterium so this
was the first proof that the DNA of the
bacteriophage went into the bacterial
cell and started the infection so before
this we didn't know we thought well
maybe it's the protein in fact many
scientists thought protein was too
genetic information because you have 21
different amino acids and only four
bases in DNA so many scientists said DNA
can't be genetic information it's not
complex enough so this was a very
important experiment not to prove that
now next time we're going to go through
all of the different kinds of viral
genomes but when we do that I want you
to remember that well they all have to
make mRNA that has to be read by
ribosomes all viruses on the planet
follow that rule no exception and
that'll help you sort it all out it
turns out that there are seven different
genome types among all the viruses and
David Baltimore who was a Nobel laureate
used this insight to unify the
classification of viruses and he says
we'll put at the center mRNA and then
every virus genome has to get to it so
he said there's seven types of viral
genes of genome actually he said they
were six then we discovered a seventh
later on double stranded DNA single
stranded DNA single-stranded RNA of
either plus or minus polarity
single-stranded sorry it's single
stranded RNA of plus or minus polarity
and then single stranded plus RNA that
goes through a DNA phase and then double
stranded RNA and then later on a seventh
class was added double-stranded DNA with
gaps and we will talk about all of those
in great detail but this is a major
unifying principle in virology so we use
this to classify viruses and again if
you don't know this terminology the plus
strand is mRNA by definition it's has
nothing to do with electricity plus or
minus it's just the randomly assigned
specification that means the Strand that
can be translated so when I say Plus RNA
I mean the Strand that can be translated
and minus is the complement and the
strand of DNA that's the plus strand is
the Strand that would be the same as
mRNA so that's what we talk about when
we say plus and minus strand and double
stranded RNA so the baltimore system
allows you knowing only the nature of
the genome to figure out all the steps
that the virus has to do in order to
replicate so by the end of the next few
lectures you'll be able to look at any
genome configuration and predict how
it's going to replicate because of this
baltimore scheme so it's a very powerful
rubric that will allow us to get through
those seven different genome types and
here they are again double-stranded DNA
gapped double-stranded DNA
single-stranded DNA and then our RNA
genomes double-stranded RNA plus or
minus single strand and then finally our
retroviruses plus stranded RNA with the
DNA intermediate so next time we're
going to go through each of these and
talk about how they work
you